♪ L'interdiction de parler
nos langues c'est un génocide ♪
♪ Tuer l'Indien à l'intérieur
d'un être humain ♪
♪ C'est un génocide
- "Génocide", c'est une chanson
coup de poing qui dénonce
avec force les traitements subis
par les Premières Nations
du Canada depuis des siècles.
Samian l'a écrite dans
la foulée de la mort de Joyce
Echaquan, cette Autochtone qui,
l'été dernier, a été abreuvée
d'insultes racistes par
le personnel soignant
de l'hôpital de Joliette,
où elle est décédée
SAMIAN, artiste
- Je me suis dit, écoute,
c'est beaucoup plus que
du racisme systémique.
On parle d'un génocide. Il faut
éviter de passer par plusieurs
chemins pour dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont.
♪ J'en ai marre des mensonges
marre de l'hypocrisie ♪
"Génocide" est la seule chanson
en français de ce cinquième
album. Les autres sont
en algonquin.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'algonquin se porte bien
au rap comme l'innu se porte
bien à la chanson. Je veux dire,
c'est une langue qui est quand
même assez sec, assez directe.
Et c'est une traduction, souvent
c'est très imagé, c'est pas
une traduction littérale.
- C'est avec sa grand-mère
que Samian a appris l'algonquin.
Né dans une réserve d'Abitibi-
Téminscamingue, dans le nord
du Québec, d'une mère algonquine
et d'un père québécois,
Samian ne parlait que français.
Sa grand-mère a été dans
les pensionnats autochtones,
ces établissements religieux
mis en place par les autorités
canadiennes au 20e siècle
pour assimiler les enfants
autochtones et leur faire
perdre leur culture.
Un ancien pensionnaire témoigne
d'ailleurs dans un clip
de Samian. Il était à Kamloop,
ce pensionnat où on a retrouvé
cet été plus de 200 dépouilles
d'enfants.
- Moi, en ce moment,
ce que je trouve difficile,
c'est le message que
le Canada envoie à l'échelle
internationale, c'est
comme si on disait :
"Il y a un génocide chez nous,
il est légal, il est impuni
et, au lieu de dénoncer
les agresseurs, on va
les protéger." C'est ce que
je trouve le plus difficile
à accepter en ce moment.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Cette colère que ressent
l'artiste de 38 ans,
il la canalise pour qu'elle
s'ouvre sur le dialogue
- Oui, je peux être en colère,
je peux l'exprimer, je vais
l'exprimer de cette façon-là,
mais, pour moi, j'ai toujours
essayé de ne pas te le gueuler
en pleine face, t'sais, je veux
dire, de ne pas être agressif,
ou de ne pas être violent
avec la musique. Donc,
le message se veut toujours
positif. J'essaye toujours
de trouver une façon de trouver
une solution.
- Et cette solution, elle passe
par une réconciliation
entre Blancs et Autochtones.
- J'ai beaucoup de misère
à croire que nos politiciens
essaient de nous vendre
une réconciliation. Moi,
je pense que c'est un peu ça,
l'idée. Puis, je pense que,
socialement, on est en avance
là-dessus.
♪ Au nom non de la mère terre
que les peuples s'unissent ♪
♪ Et qu'on enterre
la hache de guerre ♪
- Cette réconciliation, Samian
l'incarne également en étant
un pont entre les cultures
blanche et autochtone
de par son métissage.
Et il se réjouit de la place
grandissante des artistes
autochtones sur la scène
culturelle québécoise.
Il vient d'ailleurs de fonder
sa maison de production pour
offrir un tremplin aux jeunes
artistes, autochtones ou non.
Et pour se libérer des diktats
de l'industrie de la musique
et pouvoir faire les choses
à sa façon.
Ici Catherine François,
Radio-Canada, Montréa